Jimmy thing here at e3 2016 I'm here
speaking with Frank azor general manager
of Alienware and Frankie tell us what
we're looking at here so about two years
ago actually at e3 we launched the
Alienware alpha and we completely amazed
the world than we did though the amount
of performance that we had put inside
such a small package device and the
promise of the Alpha is that you're
gonna be able to run all your windows
games and do it on an extremely
affordable price a price point that was
gonna be more affordable and building
your own PC with the same specifications
this year well we've announced that the
show is the alpha or - it's the next
version of the inning where alpha and
what we've done is we've kept that
promise
but we've significantly improved the
performance that's inside the product
the new one features Intel six
generation processors it features ddr4
memory we have two graphics options as
well we have an AMD r9 470 X and we have
an NVIDIA GTX 960 desktop card in there
as well with four gigabytes of vram so
it's extremely powerful the price points
really compelling as well starts off at
just 599 dollars and the other thing
that's awesome about it is a lot of
folks when we launched the original
Alpha wanted us to give them the support
for the Alienware graphics amplifier the
graphics amplifier allows you to take a
desktop graphics card like a 970 a 1080
on AMD 490 for example a standard
off-the-shelf desktop graphics card put
it inside the amplifier and you can
connect that to any of our notebooks now
with the Alpha r2 you can connect that
to the Alpha r2 as well so if you are
for example only have maybe six or seven
hundred dollars to spend and you want a
great gaming system you could buy the r2
today save up your money six months or a
year from now buy the graphics amplifier
for 199 dollars put any desktop graphics
card in there that you want pretty much
and now you get to a path to either VR
cuz we will support VR with that or you
can even get to 4k gaming so it's a way
for the alpha or two to kind of scale
with you as your performance demands
scaled over time and one of the thing I
forgot to mention we also have the
ability for you to put both an SSD drive
and a hard
driving the new r2 as well you know the
CPU and the GPU are they using a
combination of mobile and desktop or is
it mostly desktop or can you elaborate
on that so the CPU is a desktop CPU the
graphics cards the AMD graphics card is
an AR 9 for 70 X that is a mobile GPU
part and then the nvidia gtx 960 is a
desktop part so if i got the the unit
with the AMD graphics could i you know
add in nvidia card you know with the
amplifier well right now the amplifier
only works sorry on the nvidia skew i
should i should specify that so if you
buy the AMD see you won't be able to use
the graphics amplifier if you buy the
nvidia part you can put AMD graphics in
the graphics amplifier or nvidia
graphics whichever one you'd like i know
when the first unit first came out it
was you know surrounded by the the whole
entire of steam machine hype you know
how does the system sort of panned out
as well as you'd hope or has there been
a lot of good reaction or what like what
are your thoughts on that so we're
really committed to putting pcs in the
living room this is something we've been
doing for over a decade now and
alienware has been focused on pc gaming
for over 20 years and we've had a lot of
firsts over those 20 years so CMOS and c
machine is still something that we're
committed to this will be available in
steam machine versions as well as alpha
versions with windows steam machine is
still doing well for us it didn't it
wasn't the huge success and I think
everybody anticipated it was gonna be
initially but for folks out there that
wants something that's just an appliance
like device like a real true console
with the no keyboard and mouse required
steam machines have the most compelling
devices out there right now has the
largest library of games supported and
if you don't have native steam OS
support for your game you can very
easily stream it from a Windows device
that's in the home so we think for folks
that again I just want something that
turns on and off that doesn't require
that keyboard and mouse steam machines
the perfect device and we still sell a
ton of those machines every single month
so this demand out there for it and it
makes pure sense it makes a lot of sense
for us to continue to support customers
that want that device and this is out
today this is available today absolutely
starts up a new one starts up at $5.99
and you can get an alpha or one which
we're still going to offer as low as
four
$49 cool thank you Frank for more III
coverage stay tuned to game spot calm